مساء الخير ما دام حضرتك قرار تسمعني انت
مشغول زيكو محاوله لفهم الظواهر وتربيه
الاحداث بعضها ببعض النهار ده احنا مش
بنحاول نفهم مع بعض تفسير السلوك لزعيم
سياسي معين ولا تفسير حاجز بعينه زي ما
عملنا في حلقات اخرى كثيره ولكن النهار دا
عندنا محاوله اكثر طموحا ان احنا لفهم
الصوره الخليه اللي ما يجري على الساحه
الدوليه يقول لها على كل صحه العالم
الخطوط الرئيسيه الزايد نقدر من خلال
الفهم له نفهم كثير من الاحداث على الساحه
الدوليه وتاثيرها على منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وعلى كل دول المنطقه بلدا بلد الحقيقه انه
اول مدخل علشان تحول افهم اللي بيحصل في
كل الساحه الدوليه لازم ندرك ان هناك شبه
اجماع من كل المراقبين اللي هي تبع
الاحداث الدوليه في تغيير كبير فيما يسمى
بالنظام العالم القائم نظام العالم القائم
يعني مجلس اداره العالم بعد تشكيله بين
عشان نفهم التغيير الجديد لازم نفهم الوضع
القديم والوضع القديم المستقر من بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه سنه 1945 و نظام
قائم على الهيمنه الامريكيه ان امريكا هي
رئيس مجلس اداره العالم بلادنا من اسلوب
اكبر نسبه من عدد الاسهم والقدره على
التصويت الكلام دا في شكل مؤسسات كبيره
اشرافه الولايات المتحده على تاسيسها
وتاكدت ان هذه المؤسسات سوف تح ابيها
وتحافظ على وضعها المميز سواء كانت
اتفاقيه الكاكاو منظمه التجاره العالميه
اللي موجوده دلوقتي او صندوق النقد الدولي
او البنك الدولي او المؤسسات اللي ممكن
تصفها اقتصاديه وعسكريه
وثقافيه على كل المستويات هذا النظام
اللقاء مع الولايات المتحده وتدعمها
حلفائها خصوصا حلفائها في العالم الغربي
كل دول اوروبا الغربيه واليابان واستراليا
وكندا قائم اساسه على اساس يعني العمود
الاساسي في هذا النظام هو القوه
الاقتصاديه الامريكيه المطلقه يعني فرق
جدا عضلات اقتصاديه ماهوله جدا ان تتخيلوا
العضلات الاقتصاديه الامريكيه كانت بدايه
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه ولسنوات ليست
قليله بعد كده العالم كله بين تكاد ايه
وامريكا بتنتج
امريكا التالي بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
اكثر من اربعين في المائه من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للعالم كله يعني العالم
كله كميه اكثر من اربعين وتمت به الولايات
المتحده
وصل في بعض السنوات الى خمسه واربعين في
المائه
على هذا الاساس كانت ابيك معينه تماما بعد
سنوات الحرب العالميه الثانيه رغم وجود
قوه اخرى لكن كانت اقل يعني تراجعها
عسكريا لكن لا تستطيع ان تجاريها اقتصاديه
وتاكد سيطره نفوذ الولايات المتحده وهي
امريكا على العالم مش بس خلال الحرب
البارده ولكن كمان اكثر واكثر بعد سقوط
الاتحاد السوفياتي التي استنزاف اقتصاديا
امام الولايات المتحده في مطلع التسعينيات
النظام اللي احنا نتكلم عن
الجديد ان هذا النظام اللي احنا تكلمنا
عنهم
يتداعى لنفس السبب اللي قام عليها النظام
نظام على القوه الاقتصاديه الامريكيه هذه
القوه الاقتصاديه الامريكيه تراجع بشكل
كبير مثال واحد يقول لنا على ان القوى
الاقتصاديه تراجعت انا اتكلم كم على
الجانب او الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
امريكي لديكم ارقام
وفقا لتقديرات البنك الدولي بتيجي المحل
الاجمالي الامريكي كان في سنه ستين يعادل
اربعين في المائه من اجمالي الناتج المحلي
العالمي سنه 2014 كان الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي هو الاكبر في العالم لكن فقط
عشرين في المائه يعني فقط خمسين في المائه
من حجم بسبب هذا التراجع الكبير في
الاقتصاد الامريكي من ناحيه وصعود كانت مش
موجوده على الخريطه بشكل مبكر يعني اديك
مثال بردو مثال واحد احنا طبعا بتتكلم ان
القوى الصاعده تتزعمها بشكل رئيسي الصين
اقتصاديا وكمان دول اخرى كانت انهارت
واستعرض نسبيا زي روسيا
وبالاضافه الى ظهور هو اخرى زي مجموعه دول
البريكس زي مثلا البرازيل وجنوب افريقيا
وغيرهم النووي الهند لكن لكن اناديكم رقم
واحد انه صحيح ان مازالت الولايات المتحده
بتتصدر دول العالم بيتكلم انه مثلا في سنه
2017 2016
كانت الصين حجمها من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي حوالي خمسطاشر في المائه العالم
ينتج من الصين بتمثل حوالي 14 15 في
المائه الرقم تضاعف خمسطاشر ضعف خلال
حوالي ثلاثين سنه لانه كان في الدم ارينا
ت كانت اه كانت الصين الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي يعادل تقريبا الناتج المحلي الى
بلد متوسط الحجم الاقتصاديه زي بلاده اللي
اقتصادها لا يشكل في من انتاج العالم اكثر
من واحد وواحد من عشره في المائه من
الناتج المحلي العالم فيه تقدم كبير على
مستوى الصين في تطور في دول كانت ونهارا
او كانت متخلفه ثم اصبحت مهدده وفي تراجع
كبير في الاقتصاد الامريكي النتيجه نحن
قدام نظام عالمي يتصدر وبنظام عليه يتشكل
لكنه لم يظهر الى الوجود بعد في المراحل
بيسموها مراحل انتقاليه لما يكون فيه
مرحله انتقاليه في اي ما بين اي نظام ين
من النظام العالمي القائم والنظام العالمي
اللي كان في تماما ما حصل في مراحل كثيره
في التاريخ بتبقى مرحله اضطرابات ومرحله
انعدام رؤيه عدم موضوع ومساله فيها كثير
من الالتباس فيها كثير من التوجه فيها
كثير من عدم الثقه والشك فيها كثير من
محاوله الدوله القائمه المهيمنه الولايات
المتحده وبعض حلفائها شايفين مصالحهم معها
دون بيحاولوا الحفاظ على الوضع القائم
اللي فيها والدول الصاعده الصين وروسيا
وزير هم وحلفائهم والمستفيدين من صار هم
دول بيحول يخلق واقع جديد لما يكون في هذا
ال معسكرين معسكر بحول يحافظ على الوضع
القائم ومعسكر بيحاول يخلق واقع جديد يكون
قد من الظواهر من النوعيه الى ولا
لحضراتكم والى احنا بنشوفها كل يوم في
نشرات الاخبار
الخبر رقم واحد
حروب تجاريه بين الولايات المتحده وبين
الصين التجاريه في النهايه اللي بتسمع
عنها بقا لنا من اعتقد من شهر مارس اللي
فات اول مره كان يفرض الرئيس الامريكي
تعريفه جمركيه او عقوبات اقتصاديه على
الصين وعلى غيرها الحدث انا ما بقدر في
ساحه مفتوحه التفوق الاقتصادي الصيني حاول
ا فرض سياسه حمايه لاني
المنفرد هذه السياسه في سنوات ما بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه او في الستينات
وفي السبعينات ما كانش فيه حسني حتى لو
انا فاتح كل حدودي واهلا وسهلا باي بضائع
وباي تبادل تجاري انا المتفوق كما وعددا
وبكل الاشكال فلا مانع نخلي الحدود مفتوحه
ونرحب بالبضائع تاتي وتذهب انا صاحب انا
المستفيد تغيرت الوضع امريكا لم تعد كما
كانت تنذر من قد اصبحت تستورد اكثر مما
تصدر حتى وان كانت ما زالت اصغر دول
العالم النتيجه انت عندها خوف من حاجتين
اولا ان تغرق البضائع الامريكي الصينيه
والامر الثاني ان يكون هي تتحول الى سته
وستون او حضرت صعب عليه الصين الى مرحله
اخرى مشان هي تقرب من الولايات المتحده
ولكن تتجاوزها وتتفوق عليها بحلول في
السنوات القليله القادمه او في يعني مثلا
تقديرات على الفين وخمسين يكون الاقتصاد
السنين تجاوز الاقتصاد الامريكي النتيجه
الصراع لما بنشوف صراعه اخر استعد بنسمع
انه كثير وكثير من زملائنا من اصدقائنا
الى بتابعوا القناه بيسالوني عليه الصراع
في اماكن الحيويه بالنسبه الصين في بحر
مهمه جدا منطقتنا بحر الصين الجنوبي اللي
تقع عليه كثير من الدول ال اسيا الحيويه
والمهمه هذا البحر كان منطقه نفوس كامله
للولايات المتحده بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه مع انكفاء الصين لاكثر من عشرين
ثلاثين سنه على نفسها وقتها كانت الصين
بيقول انا بلد فقير بلد غالب ان كل طموحي
تداوله من دول العالم الثالث اننا وكل هذا
الشعب الشعب اللي بيعتبر اكبر الشعب على
مستوى العالم اكثر من مليار وثلاثمائه
مليون يعني ادوا كل الولايات المتحده
ثلاثمائه مليون وعليهم مليار كمال فانا لا
انافس احدا ابدا لكن بالوقت مع الصعود
الاقتصادي ومع التطور واصبحت الصين ب
تنافس الولايات المتحده اقتصاديه تغيرت
الله وتغير مستوى الطموحات واصبحت تنظر في
محيطها وعاوز تعزز من نفوذها العسكري
والسياسي وبدات في كل يوم تصادم ما بين
الاساطيل الصينيه والاساطيل الامريكيه بس
مش على مستوى العالم في منطقه الصين
حوليها في بطنها في الاماكن اللي بتعتبرها
اماكن استراتيجيه وحيويه ليله ومنطقه بحر
الصين الجنوبي الذي
اتهامات يوميه من الامريكان بانه الصين
بتتحرك به الاساطيل الامريكيه ان الصين
بتتحرك في الدول ال حليفه للولايات
المتحده ان الصين
يبني جزر صناعيه في منطقه البحر السنه
الجنوبي علشان توسع من مناطق حدودها
الاقليميه وبالتالي تقدر ان هي طبعا سوف
انها واسط لها وصواريخ في صدام الصدام
وشاركت في بس في الحروب التجاريه ولم
يحتفلوا ولم يقتصر فقط على منطقه بحر
الصين الجنوبي احنا الان ان الصين دلوقتي
بعد تبني قواعد عسكريه سواء في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وفي اماكن اخرى خارج الشرق
الاوسط والان اه في سنه 2013
طرحت الصين تصور مش دوله من دول العالم
الثالث كان نقول تتصور انها تقوم به
العالم من خلال ما يسمى الموضوع اللي
عملناه اللي هي الدول الحزام الطريق
وتكلمنا عنه في فيديو ارض ومحاضرات يرجعون
وهو احد التصورات في قياده العالم انهى
تقود على الضخم جدا يتجاوز الى ان ضروري
الان اكثر من ثلاثه وسبعين دوله تربطهم
الصين كلها بشبكه ضخمه جدا من الطرق
والكباري محطه الكهرباء والطاقه
والتكنولوجيا او شركات الاتصالات الى اخره
الصين تقدم الولايات المتحده تقهقر في ظل
تقهقر الولايات المتحده وقوفها الشديد من
الصين اللي تكلمنا بردو عمره في حلقات
اخرى انتو ترجعوا بس مش موضوعنا المعارضه
بنشوف مجموعه من الظواهر احد الظواهر
عدم قدره الولايات المتحده ان هي تمارس
مهامها الامبراطوريه كما اعتادت من قبل
فتنسحب من بعض الاماكن
لما تنسحب من بعض الاماكن لانها غير قادره
على التكلفه لازم يملا هذا الفراغ قوى
اخرى احد المناطق
الساعه الولايات المتحده الانسحاب فيها من
سنوات نلاقي مثلا منطقه الشرق الاوسط وما
لانه غير راغب في البقاء في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط انها وجه كل القرارات العسكريه
السياسيه لمواجهه الصين في اسيا لما يحاول
اوباما يعمل الكلام ده بالمناسبه مش مختلف
كثير عن قرب في هذا الصدد كانت النتيجه
انه الدول
اليك على وجه التحديد وجدت نفسها ان هي
بلاء لاول مره منذ استقلالها معظم الدول
الخليجيه استقل او تشكل الحديث كدوله انما
كان عنده حمايه زي مثلا سلطنه عمان او كان
الدول المحتله احتلالا واضحا استقلت تماما
سيد معظم دول الخليج استثنائي السعوديه
الكامل في الثلاثينات هذه الدول وقدرت
نفسها لاول مره منذ استقلالها انهى باقل
قدر ممكن من الحمايه الامريكيه النتيجه
انها بدات هذه الدول تسلك سلوك الدوله
اللي تبناها القومي في انها تقدم بدائل
تمثلت البدائل في ايه كميه ضخمه جدا من
السلاح بتشتريها الامارات والبحرين
والتشريعيه السعوديه وتشتريها الكويت
والقدر كذلك مشتركه من الضخمه جدا من
الصلاح 2
ومحاوله ايجاد صيغ مختلفه للدفاع عن نفسها
يفكروا في الناتو العربي فكروا في القوات
العربيه المشتركه يفكروا فيه القوات
الباكستان الباكستان هو الباكستان يفكروا
في الاستعانه بمصر في بدائل مختلفه بعضها
ب يتعذر بعضها مابين بعضها ما زال في
مرحله التشكيل لكن الاخطر من كل ده ان
اسرائيل للثلث تشوفوا فهم اللي يجري عن
العالم ومحبه تستغل حاجتين واحده منهم
انسحاب الامريكي الثاني ها تكلم عنها بعد
شويه وقت تطرح نفسها للدول العربيه
والخارجيه اللي محتاجه حليفه تقول لهم اذا
كانت الولايات المتحده الاسباب قررت
الانسحاب في المنطقه انا اقدر اكون شركه
مش بس مش ابعدو يكون شريك وادافع معاكم
عنكم ضد اخبار كثيره على راسها ايران
وعلشان اسرائيل تنجح في المساله ديه
بتشتغل طبعا
فكره للسيطره على المنطقه وتستغل الخوف
دول الخليج تحديدا من ايران وبعض هذه
المخاوف المر وبعضها غير مبرر وبدات تقدم
نفسها كشريك وعلشان كده نشوف الصغار
الكثيره اللي موجوده سواء الى ياه او
المسؤولين مختلفين في دول الخليج التي لم
تعد تخ تخفي رغبتها في التعاون مع اسرائيل
لان اسرائيل عندها ما تقدمه وامريكا لا
تمانع في هذه الخطوه لانه اسرائيل شركتها
الى مقدرش عمل وتعمله اسرائيل يكون
امريكيه تطور اخر ما تنسوش اللي في اطار
انسحاب الولايات المتحده
بوست ازمتها وتراجعها يحصل نوع كثير من
الغضب الشعبي داخل بعض فئات المجتمع
الامريكي اللي تشعر انه هما فقد كثير من
مزايا هم وما فقدوا كثير من مزايا هم بسبب
التراجع الاقتصادي
لكن تصورهم انهم فقدوا كثير من مزايا هم
بسبب فشل النخب الحاكمه اللي كانت موجوده
لما من الشعب يفشل او
النخب الحاكمه اليوم تتمثل في التيارات
المعتدله اللي حكمت امريكا من بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لغايه دلوقتي اذا ما
شرحنا في حلقه التيارات اليمينيه النتيجه
بيكون ظهور تيارات شعبويه تيارات متطرفه
جدا
ابرزها اللي زي ما تكلمنا قبل كده ظهر في
امريكا
وظهر في دول اخرى سيارات دينيه متشدده
عوده تستعيد الماضيه وعلشان تستعين المجد
الماضي المد الاصولي فلوسنا امريكا بس على
سبيل المثال ما بدها القائمه على الانتاج
الانتاج الوفير هي مش قادره تعمل ان توفير
فالنتيجه تعمل حرب تكريس قلت لكم النتيجه
بمنطقه التاجي عندما يفلس يفتش في دفاتره
القديمه
النتيجه انه ويبتدي يشوف انا ممكن قلت
النفقات وعزز وعظم الايرادات يفرض ما يسمى
اخشى اقرب الى الاتاوه يروح لدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ويهددهم تدفعوا اللي عليكم لازم
تدفعوا او مشاهديك م
دول الخليج لازم تدفع لانها بدون سوف تسقط
خلال اسبوعين يدفعوا اول نحميهم لازم
تشتري سلاح لازم تستثمر اكثر احنا بن شارك
فيه احنا بتشارك فيه مثلا اتفاقات احنا ما
نعين بعض الانشطه الاقتصاديه
حفاظا على البيئه هل تذهب البيئه للجحيم
احنا نستثمر في البحر وان نستثمر في
الطاقه غير نظيفه عشان ناس تلاقي فرص عمل
احنا احنا بن تولى قياده العالم واحمي
المسؤولين عن العولمه او فتح الاصوات انا
متضرر منها انا مش عاوز العولمه انا عاوز
فرص العمل بدات الولايات المتحده وكانها
وعاد العالم كله احد
تغير النظام اللي موجود
النتيجه ضربه بالنتيجه انه التغير هذا
المصاب اللي موجود انه بقي عندي اطماع
كثيره مش بس من جانب اسرائيل لان تكلمت
عنها ولكن كمان من دول اخرى في ايران
وتركيا كل واحده من الدول اللي بتحاول
الفراغ اللي ثابته الولايات المتحده اما
بالتعاون مع امريكا في اسرائيل او
بالتعاون مع امريكا في فتره من الفترات هي
رجب طيب اردوغان اللي حاول يقنع الولايات
المتحده انه ممكن يعيد تشكيل المنطقه بحيث
تحكمها احزاب اسلاميه بقيادته او حتى
ايران اللي بتحاول تستعيد ماجد الماضي
زينا روسيا حول الصين عام لك واحب تستغل
الفراغ وتتمدد في كامل المقلقه النتيجه
رغم التضارب
ايران
وتركيا واسرائيل ورغم تراجع امريكا وتضرب
قراراتها هو اللي الدولي
بتواجه بتلعب انا فيما يتعلق بالمنطقه
العربيه مش المنطقه العربيه بس انا اتكلم
لاننا معنيين بالمنطقه العربيه كلهم
بيتفقوا على ان مصالحهم بوش في تفتيت
الدول العربيه زي ما كانت سبيكه بنت
معناها موجات الهجره حضر اليوم ولكن في
اضعاف الدول المركزيه
الدوله موجوده لكن دوله ضعيفه مكونه من
دويلات صغيره ربما يجمعها مثلا دوله
فيدراليه في وضع في العراق هي وضع في
سوريا سيما ممكن يحصل في اليمن صوره لنادي
صوره بانوراميه او صوره عامه للمشهد على
الساحه الدوليه وعلى الساحه المحليه
المؤكد انه كل انواع الصراع سوف تظل
والانواع المعاناه في المنطقه سوف تظل
مستمره حتى يتشكل نظام عالمي جديد
طبعا تصبح تحتفظ فيه الدول الكبيره باوزان
اكبر بكثير من الاوزان الدول العربيه
مكانها في النظام الحاله العالمي القائم
وفي النظام القائم في النظام العالمي
القادم او الحالي هو تقدر تقول كده اذا
كانو هم الافيال فنحن العشر يعني احنا
نقول ضحيه هذه الصراعات والحلقه الاضعف
فيها اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]